ah
tienes
que tengan las estrellas
con todas
si no la conocía muchas condiciones
porque nos interesamos
nos acaba de decir
el apetito
expresamente las especificaciones
estaba brillando
la publicidad en el cine
a participar
el país
regiones físicas
de la ciudad
de normalizar
tenemos algunos servicios
escribe
pero además hay una rebelión de
entidades físicas
por qué
bueno somos muy pocas
pero además estudiantes de situaciones
decidiendo césar ya que ambos en
situaciones de energía de intereses o
bueno muchas frecuencias ocupan las
páginas más bajas opciones regionales
más bajos y además hay un punto que hay
diferencias regionales que quiere decir
que los países desarrollados hay menos
de red física
ellos están en desarrollo
para saber para tener mayor comentario
es la preocupación de la comunidad nos
llega nos lleva a formar un grupo de
trabajo que es esta
y esa fue la primera porque cada tres
años los mismos para precisamente
hablarles
como van
como otras mujeres han desarrollado su
carrera en un ambiente de hombres
aprendemos una de otra de mis clases
reyes
por ejemplo si todos estos premios que
cargamos
entre hombres y mujeres entre razas
entre culturas
precisamente todas esas actividades
vivimos
pero
además tenemos encuentros regionales
decirlo
hoy
continentes
y esta es nuestra región latinoamérica
tenemos allí las físicas
latinoamericanas y tenemos entonces una
convivencia que nos une muchísimo por
nuestro pasado nuestro siglo
por ejemplo en nuestros países
no sé también un bajo porcentaje de
gasto investigación
[Música]
es más grande en nuestra región en
promedio es de 0 57 % los países es más
describió entonces tenemos que adquirir
en esta realidad y también lo que nos
une es la inestabilidad
si bien ahora de 07 en el próximo
gobierno en muchos países
sean mucho menos
y esta es nuestra realidad y por eso
tenemos que vivir
también es otra realidad que es muy
interesante
cuántos años
una persona
y responden nuestros países
curiosamente en latinoamérica las
ministerios tienen una mayor
una desigualdad que hay que resolver a
favor de los hombres
ahora cuando los vamos a iniciar les
es algo que llama la atención de muchos
países
pero no solamente son números detrás de
esos números que pasan por esas mujeres
cuando se mira lo que comprendan todas
estas situaciones la doble carga
excederá que hay detrás de estas mujeres
están realizan la investigación
y entonces este es nuestro grande
y entonces ahorita es que estoy pensando
con ingresando las clases para terminar
una maestría en una preparatoria y los
estudiantes
muchos estudian cualquiera
andrés estudiantes del mundo la sola
idea
a través de imaginarios entonces cómo
podemos hacer que estos jóvenes en medio
de esas flores en aquel estado minas y
robles de 22 años ayudando en la escuela
puede haber una de ellas emociones su
vida la favores científica dejarse hacer
investigación para descubrir todos los
fenómenos desarrollar los extremos de la
naturaleza
estabilidad y racionales es tan hábil
como para desarrollar toda su
potencialidad en un ambiente determinado
por el machismo está en todos los
ámbitos de interés realidad porque esta
artista cómo podemos hacer que puedan
desarrollar esta cadena de la mejor
manera posible en unas éxitos
que nos va a aportar ahora entonces pues
en muchas actividades
los seguimientos ahora tres años para
tres años
semos lares y el último trabajo que
estamos haciendo es una encuesta mundial
porque es de los valientes de las
visitas es ingeniera de todos los
cambios científicos y entonces nos hemos
criado gran con matemáticas en las
juntas en nuestras misiones científicas
hemos desarrollado una encuesta y que
tengo sobre mi piel no solamente para
situaciones en dragones y mujeres
la encuesta mujeres son para mujeres y
los bienes cuenta que no podíamos
comparar con el de los hombres y
entonces después ahora hemos incorporado
también los hombres también para
permitir desarrollar análisis sobre las
diferencias
las disciplinas tecnológicas y otras
finalmente también no sólo las
religiones sino también como países como
parte de este proyecto que se llama
precisamente de género y ciencia como de
vila y cómo reducirla también estamos
recordando todas las experiencias
y una tarde numérica no es también
estamos ubicado un libro que se llama la
belleza de género la temática es
publicación y ciencias naturales un
abordaje de américa latina en el que
estamos operando parte de todas estas
experiencias justamente para compartir
para que las demás así como nosotros
tenemos en realidad en donde las mujeres
entonces también podemos tener un acceso
a esta información
les dejan se van formando los que van
construyendo redes logrando condensarse
en un confidente en una región es
precisamente américa latina y todos los
obra literaria permite el error está
estafando el desarrollo de las mujeres
en la ciencia
y
para ser honesta los proyectos para mis
estudiantes etcétera no solamente el
colegio sino que también está generando
noticia algún grande para nuestro país y
porque ahora además asumiendo de este
compromiso con el general o con
programas especiales para las mujeres
como es este programa para madres
solteras
por alguna razón de familia deja un
programa especial a las mujeres
indígenas que les permite sustantiva
por su condición
y así muchos otros seres que están
promoviendo para incorporar a las
mujeres el desarrollo de nuestro país
cuando es otra vez en este pueblo
electrónico
y entonces pienso que no solamente ha
sido país
muerto de camino
sales
y lo más importante
más importante de todo han sido en este
momento todas las amigas
y en las que planeamos estuvimos
analizando hacemos nuestros boletos con
la mente satisfacción y ninguna
actividad concluir esa felicidad de los
desarrollos algo que sí será un trayecto
de harina donde esa red
eso también en algún día de los jóvenes
posteriores que organizamos
algunas visitas
[Música]